what I guess one of us didn't get the
memo I don't know what is this you is
this what you guys are wearing yeah
the invitation said dress appropriately
I appreciate it a text or something
yeah no you don't know hey I swear to
God I yeah he and I are wearing suits
yeah what do they kill just your
long-term memory is bad yeah I've been
here before you know we wear suits
yes we always wear suits we've been
wearing suits on this show since 1993
you look good dude thank you very much
yeah I went and saw you backstage and
you were dressed like that and then I
said I better get out of your dressing
room and I didn't say this but mine is
thinking he's got to get into his suit I
noticed you didn't mention it no I
didn't mention it because I've seen
guess you know dressed casually before
and I chat them up before I go and and
you know I just make sure they're sober
and they're cool and then and then I
love which we're not sure you're either
yeah I wanted to I can guarantee that
yeah cool yeah I think you're here to
sell us weed
I think it's quite clear oh I see you
got your tennis t-shirt I want to play a
little tennis this morning you are you
like tennis I did oh yeah I do that's
how you do it that's how you play tennis
you try a racquet sometime you might
like it it's funny dude good ones yeah
and he knows I feel this way about him
yeah I know as you know there's it work
we Conan our friends yeah and he knows
he knows that you how I fell out of that
I can change
commercial break coming up I like I can
run back it'd be like a t Swift concert
yeah have a different outfit every time
that's all right no now you're a big let
me tell you something yeah I mean this I
don't care how many talk shows out there
who's hot who's the latest whatever the
end of the day on this network at this
hour there's nobody
we're not
I mean that I know you mean it I know
you mean it now you said you've been
playing tennis oh you were just in New
York for the USL US Open did you have a
good time oh great time I love that
eleventh you get more relaxed come on
I love anyone tuning in right now you're
there and you should just take a nap on
the couch
I can't I'm too distracted by his toes I
know that's now you've made me so kind
no I cover those babies up drop
something on one up into the two yeah
you do have a bruise on your toe is the
kind of show we run
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my god I was drawn to the Bruce is
attracted that's because I'm an athlete
Oh any kind of athletes like me and like
Pele we got very sick you've seen that
photo
sure same kind of
you